A QUICK SPIN THROUGH IN FRONT
AND PETTERSSON HAD IT  AROUND
AND BESSER WILL CLEAR IT AHEHE
THE FLOWER.
>> EDDIE: HE SAID TO BE GREATER
DACH.
HE'S GOING TO GET THIS PUCK AND
HE'S GOIWITH
KURASHEV.
JACOBSON WILL SEND WITH A GOAL
YOU'LL TAKE ANYTHING YOU
TIP SOMEHOW.
>> Pat: I WOULD SAY KEVIN
SHATTENKIRK IS PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE ON THE LEADERBOARD
WITH  THAT UP.
THE CONNECTS CLEAR IT AHEAD.
OSS TO THE
CALGARY FLAMES, THTH
WAY AND ITrick: IT'S ON THE WALD
KANE THROWN NEAR THE NET.
KANE TAKING A HERE,  ON THE KAN
THERE.
I LIKE WHEN HE REL
FLEURY, REBOUND TAKEN BY MYERS.
PUT IN DEEP. DAY ,
SHARPIE.
>> PPORTUNITY.
DIDN'T GET A LOT ON IT  BUT HE
AND AGAIN THE HAWKS ARE
CHANGING ON THIS SHIFT.
NOW HAGEL COMING UP WITH IT,
HE TURNS IT BOESER ABLE TO
TIP IT HOME.
ACTIVE DEFENSE WITH
REDIRECT HIT CALEB JONES ON THE
WAY.
NOW ING,
CAN OX.
>> Eddie: WHAT BIG HIT
BUT PLAYED IT AROUNDLK ABOUT A K
CH
LOOSE
EVERYTHING ON THAT HE  MOVING
FORWARD.TV TIMEOUT.
JUMPING IN THE PLAY TO TURN A
THREE ON THREE INTO A FOUR ON
THREE TYPE OF SITUATION OFF TH
>> Eddie: DEFENSEMAN GETTING
ACTIVE.
SHOOT THE PUCK , YOU JUST NEVER
KNOW.  OTHER SIDE.
HAGEL IST AND IT'S BLOCKED AND
TURNED THE OTHER WAY FOR AN
EMPTY NET